this is one way to put a friendship to
the test the Golden Globes as fitted
Jennifer Lawrence against her new BFF
Amy Schumer how about that this is a big
day in Hollywood we have the surprises
the snubs a ton of great reaction from
the nominees and of course our panel of
experts in the house to break it all
down and speaking of celeb reaction well
guess who was on the phone right now Amy
Schumer aunt baby how are you I'm drunk
so much for having me back we're I'm in
the writers room from a TV show and they
they surprised me with champagne Amy
here's what I want to know how did you
find out and have you talked to Jennifer
Lawrence yeah I found out in bed alone
as I unfortunately I'm both fun and I
haven't connected with Jen yet but i did
send her respect i just want to know a
sentient raise your BFF and you are in
the same categories is the friendship
gonna be able to survive no the
friendship is completely over I just
blocked her number um it's over well
before Amy called us she posted this
adorable throwback Thursday photo joking
quote me with my first globe predicting
this moment Thank You Hollywood Foreign
Press and we congratulate to rob lowe
today it never gets old Rob Lowe the
grinder it's a breakthrough you know
ostensibly with six episodes out there
it means we're doing something right
Gina Rodriguez jane the virgin and gina
was thrilled today she rushed to our
leanne aguilera and toasted with wet
second Golden Globe nomination crazy how
are you feeling right now I'm shvitzing
this morning gina was Miss identified
and a Golden Globe goof just as America
Ferrera took the podium to announce
today's noms the globe's tweeted a pic
of the moment calling America Gina oh
who cares who cares
America's love leave anybody I want to
get mixed up with its her Gina brushed
it off and there was a quick apology
from the Hollywood Foreign Press quote
what occurred this morning was an
unfortunate error our sincerest
apologies to both America and Gina Thank
You Nancy pay the soul mate of course
last year before Gina won the globe we
named her our breakout store whoo and
this season it was Rachel blues yeah
it's been a crazy day Rachel bloom crazy
ex-girlfriend
uh it's great where were you when you
found out what song and dance did you do
I was in a robe and then I did a happy
dance with my husband next stallone
packs a punch Sylvester Stallone Creed
you show me something slide called his
first nomination since rocky and
unexpected honor